ladies and gentlemen welcome to reddit
saturdays we talk about the memes guys
another one okay it's another one we're
getting into it today
got a huge announcement at the end of
this but
before i get to that guys let's see what
you guys have been doing
right in my absence what have you guys
been up to
brian interviewing the metacore guy do
the skinny people cringe and say
don't tell them that metacore yes yes
don't tell them what you know keep them
fat guys if you don't know we're talking
about robert kiyosaki's famous
meme here do the rich people cringe and
say don't tell them that
yes yes yes don't tell people but they
what you know people poor
keep a bar oh we cringe for another
reason entirely trust me
anyone fancy it joining me live today
nope
no no no thanks actually a lot of brian
posts let me say right in advance i'd
love to play you some of brian
shenanigans but uh mr free speech
yeah he took down my drip video drip
podcast took down the whole four-hour
livestream
i clipped out the clip that he
copyrighted he copyright claimed it
again
so uh mr free speech he doesn't actually
like it
when it's turned against him he only
likes it when he's doing it you get it
i've heard you say many times and i get
goosebumps
each time i hear you say it
i might not agree with everything you
have to say but i will defend to the
death
your right to say it why are you willing
to stand up for
even people being able to speak their
minds
when you disagree with them yeah so it's
a great question and
financial markets keep getting worse
taking people's money
do you have only for forex how do we
split the profit all profit is split 50
50. jeez guys
don't do this please right now the
market's never been worse
uh for stock scams please guys please go
with the registered broker please go
into like
long-term you know value investing
please
uh it's a good way to not lose all your
money when a scammer arrives in the
wrong neighborhood
a scammer trying to peddle his course
coffee is the list spencer cornelius
mike win it that's how it be guys uh
trying to trying to keep this place safe
for you guys stumbling around
falling into pyramid schemes okay bot
fab 100
calls on dollar sign zella get the new
ticker guys just ipod we're launching
off get in on the ground floor of the
most exciting opportunity of your life
look put in your likes your
subscriptions now
because we're closing it all down in
march not allowed to invest in march so
get in and fab
coffee's advertising youtube ads why is
that coffeezilla advertises and works
with youtube promoting ads that are
scamming our community i heard adblock
can work how do y'all do it i can't
figure it out
guys first of all use adblock like the
rest of us normal mortals
okay or get youtube red first of all i
don't choose the ads that get placed on
my youtube channel
and that's number one number two i don't
feel bad about taking scammers money i'm
gonna be honest nobody in my community
is falling for this stuff
okay please don't i mean we we tell you
it
but i've actually heard from multiple
people that it's like a weird
almost reinforcement of what we talk
about all the time on this channel
where we're talking about like scams and
people go oh it's not a big deal that's
the thing that i get the most when they
first start watching my channel they go
hey what's the what's the big deal
really and then
they get like five ads in and they go oh
this is
this is way worse than i thought so
basically youtube automatically
puts us into uh the the tags based on
like the auto generated tags
because they see that the community that
watches me also watches
you know all those guys uh but we're
trying to pull you out of that world
guys
eventually we're gonna be out of there
hopefully nobody watches that stuff
anymore
and then our ad base or whatever can
shift
out of that towards something more
wholesome like uh i don't know
coca-cola or uh sketchers i don't know
bottom line is guys i don't choose who
advertises on my channel but
i also don't feel bad about it either
because we're educating people
about what not to do when you see an
audit on brian rose's social accounts
and you see that he has 41
fake followers okay
41 suspicious interesting
interesting and i have to keep an eye on
that
literally such a bummer that we can't
talk about brian rose i'm honestly
thinking of petitioning to make a
freedom platform
ourselves you guys want to pitch jen
coughs when he realizes that he can make
free ebooks and courses about how to
speak
how to about how to spot fake gurus oh
yeah
it's all coming together have you not
already seen my free video about this
hey
free video go watch my live webinar yeah
but honestly i have thought about uh
making a fake ad before i do think that
would be really funny like using all
their tactics like
hey guys you can learn the secret to
getting rich using a technique
only known by a rare zimbabwe island
natives
do this to get marriage oh the feed your
mind starter pack
ooh remove tony robins dean graziosite
lopez grant cardone dan lok robert
kiyosaki about procter
i don't know warren buffett's legit
jordan belfort definitely remove him
definitely remove napoleon hill yeah
warren buffett definitely belongs on
this list over here
uh carlo young foreign this is like more
of philosophy but if you actually just
want to feed your mind in finance
there's a lot of great people
in finance as well in fact maybe you
should start with warren buffett's
favorite
uh guy benjamin graham the intelligent
investor or a random walk down wall
street
or influenced by robert caldini or the
power of habit by charles dewig
look guys are we going to start a book
club eventually i feel like we need to
i saw coffee's twitter post about making
a soundtrack so i went ahead and tried
making some let's check this out
okay full disclosure i've already seen
this it's amazing
i know what you mean this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick trying to sell
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey that's professional that's
professional listen we've listened to a
lot of songs
that's the first one that i feel like
could go on spotify right now uh
awesome awesome awesome i'm working
right now to get it cleared
for youtube use i honestly i want to
make that our new intro or outro or
something
how awesome is that uh want to give this
guy a huge
shout out anton pax guys keep an eye out
for this guy here's his love i think you
can find him on spotify
incredible incredible my man's going
places in the coffee's little community
at minimum you're now hey
congratulations you're famous immediate
platinum for that epic
give boom platinum baby
caleb maddox post dude this guy's
non-stop content a hundred million
dollars plus in 2021 is inevitable
screenshot this and keep me accountable
on new year's 2022. oh
no caleb
oh my man's going for the maximum wage
he says 100 million dollars of course
sales
for sure i can get you guys to buy in
that screenshot it guys
uh we will remind them this is getting
out of hand they're flooding clubhouse
now
oh yeah i've seen this guys i know all
of you guys are dming me to do a video
about this i'm going to do a video about
clubhouse
chidster all these guys are all on here
and they were doing this thing for a
while where they were faking
instagram verification in their profiles
so they'd like have a clubhouse profile
it wouldn't be verified but then they'd
have a blue check mark next to their
name their face
it was ridiculous and it still is
ridiculous mods are asleep zilla is
taking a break post yoga gurus
not allowed not a band hey
how do i ban this guy you do
the crime you do the time
brian zimmer rose when old bribre gets
caught for his shenanigans
i can't walk guys this is a reference to
the drip
podcast which you go subscribe to if you
want um
where we talked about how it seems like
anytime anybody gets caught for
you know some kind of crime they go from
fully able-bodied to
hobbling on a cane the next day we're
referencing harvey weinstein but
you know what bribry when he gets
arrested probably pull out the walker
too
scamish is savage get him swag
he did say that i couldn't believe it i
was like amish
camish uh he said he said that before he
knew what was really going down he said
he said he's yelling at the at the
youtube videos get him swag
honestly can't blame him 2k subscribers
well done memers guys get in
our slash coffee cellar underscore gg
join the movement
big chungus rose you got a tight little
man
no this is not right hey warner bros
called um they want their ip back
another big l for brian rose today dude
we're just all about the brian rose
stuff today
fake guru gets caught out on his
credentials gets big mad what are you
talking about i'm not mad i am bad
i would hope that at the top of this
people are getting popular disseminating
good information and not being grossly
irresponsible and hyping everybody up on
a bunch of stuff that i would have
expected you to know wasn't true
and i want you to justify did destiny
just zilla this man yo
you know me and destiny we're almost the
same person he's half cuban i'm half
cuban
his name is steven my name's steven i
actually think that's where the
similarities
end actually i'm just saying maybe he's
trying to copy coffeezilla i don't know
i like it though i like i mean i'm down
with it i don't care kevin david copied
other's content for his own benefits
people may think of his own ideas but
it's not fu copycat kevin what is this
those who are planning to be businessman
may understand efforts create a business
so he says steps to start a business
and then you google starting a business
the balance
and everything lines up perfectly
editor can i'm sorry can we do a little
side by side there
seriously look look at these two they're
the exact same
uh ladies and gentlemen i i rest my case
okay kevin david has not changed one bit
baby
why would brian need to edit a two-word
post because he hasn't got a clue where
he is
oh it looks like in this post oh my gosh
he goes
hello hackney and then he edited it over
on his youtube page
to say hi knew him oh gosh
that uh guys he's from america what do
you expect he's an american trying to
run for mayor of london
okay what do coffeezilla and kim
kardashian have in common i don't know
uh that we're both highly fashionable i
don't know what do you think
they both hobbits okay
hey we need to have some respect around
here some ground rules guys
there needs to be some respect for me
i'm not sensing that from you guys right
now
um and i don't like it [ __ ] how you not
the hobbit again okay this is the last
thing i wanted to show you guys because
it leads into our big announcement
oh a little post from our boy billy jean
is marketing
now i don't think i've said that much
negative about this guy besides just say
laughing at him for fake retiring uh but
he goes anybody know
this i'm not even going to say that word
hey
belly gene you watch your mouth your
dirty mouth right now
at coffee break underscore yt he has an
entire youtube channel
dedicated to try to tear down other
people says a bunch of
i promise he'd never say to their faces
well we'll see about that billy
insecure and damaged little trying to
hurt people because he's hurt and feels
insignificant
tag ah
stop it tag this boy in the comments
we're gonna have
a conversation guys so he posts this on
i guess
instagram um immediately deletes it
so then he dm's me guys and
well i set up i set up the debate
of course that's what i wanted to
announce we're debating
12 30 pst this thursday guys
live aka 230 cst if you're like me uh
yeah so we'll see we'll see what he did
by the way by the when i
started talking to him he had already
deleted the post so i don't know he's
coming in hot
okay and it should be very interesting
to talk to him i think we're gonna have
a
great time have been a little while
since we've had a nice little debate
live debate gonna be fun am i fake news
guys am
am i uh insecure and hurt by the way how
are you gonna call me this i mean i
i have been married and then like been
with the same girl for 12
years i don't know that that really
applies billie jean is marketing
we'll see we'll see it's going to be a
fun time we're going to go through it
all
okay so if you want to see me talk to
him
we're going to go ahead and do a live
thing and i think he's going to upload
it as a podcast later
but you know it's funny i think it's
great we'll see if i can say stuff to
his face
that uh he promises i will never say so
it's going to be a good time
all right so that's basically it guys
keep bringing on the memes i love to see
them
thanks for watching pump the stock and i
will see you
[Music]
tomorrow
[Music]
please
[Music]
nothing but a trick trying to sell me on
a dream but that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee
you just want my dollar bills i got this
funny feel that what you made of who you
are is really nothing real
you trying to
[Music]
never stop until there's no more